let's look at a square of side one
centimeter each
it's always a good idea to write the
length next to the respective sides
what is the area of the square
perimeter can be calculated as four
multiplied by one centimeter which
equals four centimeters
the area of this square is one square
centimeters
this can also be written as one
centimeter squared
this area of one centimeter squared will
be the standard unit we use to find the
areas of smaller rectangles or squares
now let's look at a rectangle of length
five centimeters and breadth four
centimeters
how do we find the area of this
rectangle
let us split five centimeters into five
columns of one centimeter each
so we draw four lines like these
distance between any two adjacent
vertical lines is one centimeter
and we split four centimeters into rows
of one centimeter each
so we draw three lines like these
even the distance between any two
adjacent horizontal lines is one
centimeter
we haven't done anything special
we have just drawn lines within the
figure
and what we got is 20 small squares of
side one centimeter each
each of these tiny squares inside will
have sides of length one centimeter
which means we have 20 small squares of
area one square centimeter
so if we add up the area of each of the
20 squares
we get the total area as 20 square
centimeters
that is actually equal to 5 multiplied
by 4 squared centimeters
that's how we get the formula of the
area of a rectangle as length multiplied
by breadth
we break the rectangle down to tiny
squares of standard size
so if we have a rectangle of length l
and breadth b
the area of the rectangle will be l
multiplied by b
if we have a square of sides s
centimeters
then the area of the square will be s
multiplied by s squared centimeters
that equals s squared squared
centimeters
we get s multiplied by s since the
square is another form of a rectangle
it is basically a rectangle with the
same length and breadth
now let's consider the same figure we
saw in the earlier video
we have four equilateral triangles on
the four sides of the square in between
the side of the square is given as 5
centimeters
in this example though we have to find
the area of the figure
since all the triangles are equilateral
the lengths of their sides will be 5
centimeters
so we mark the lengths of the triangles
as five centimeters
so the total area of this figure will be
the area of the square plus the area of
the four triangles
for the perimeter however
we just considered the outer edges and
ignored the edges of the square
you